hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
some of you may remember back in october
2017
astronomers announced they discovered an
interstellar
interloper in our solar system there was
an
object which they dubbed amumua which
was flying through our solar system
it was much like a comet but comets come
from the outer solar system they're in
orbit around the sun very gently and
then something knocks them out of their
orbit
so they dive in closer to the sun and we
can see them
by contrast was moving so fast that it
was clearly not
bound to the sun gravitationally it came
from way beyond the solar system and
after it zoomed by the sun it's going to
return back to
interstellar space so of course
astronomers are very excited by this
this is the first
ever interstellar object in our
neighborhood that we could see up close
and personally
and many of them analyzed it they wrote
papers
one such paper came out a year later by
javi loeb who is a professor at the
harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics
and shmuel bialy who was a postdoc at
harvard also
and it had the dry title of could solar
radiation pressure
explain amumua's peculiar acceleration
and they go through and they do
calculations and all these things
near the end of that paper there's one
little paragraph which
off-handedly they say you know it's
possible
muammua is not a rock it's possible that
it's not
just a naturally occurring object at all
but is in fact constructed by an
advanced
technological civilization outside of
our solar system and it was
targeted to go near the sun perhaps with
a solar sail
or something like that again one little
paragraph they didn't make a big deal
out of it but guess what
the world made a big deal out of it this
was discovered by people on the internet
and suddenly
harvard scientists suggesting alien
presence here in the solar system right
so when that happens you know you have
to understand
when scientists think about different
hypotheses for explaining the world
they're very ready to explore all sorts
of different possibilities
just because they say that a possibility
is conceivable doesn't mean they think
that it's
likely you should get excited about it
right we're going to put all the
hypotheses on the table
and then decide what we want but given
all this pressure the sort of different
things you could do you could say well
oh sorry you know don't take me too
seriously we didn't really mean it etc
avi loeb in particular decided to go the
other way he doubled down he said no no
this really is possible we should really
take this seriously and got enormous
amount of criticism
for that many other astronomers and many
people in the media said
that's not a good hypothesis it does not
fit the data and they offered reasonable
reasons
to say that so i'm not going to
personally
judge whether it is likely that amumua
was or was not
an alien artifact we'll talk about that
in this podcast interview with avi loeb
but i think that there are more
important things that we're talking
about so
one thing we're talking about is a
muammua okay we're going to talk about
whether or not
it is reasonable to think that this is
an alien artifact or is it something
else right is it you know a rock or a
comet or whatever
the second thing we're going to talk
about is what is the attitude we should
have
toward more dramatic ideas
okay so should you hide them should you
put them front and center should you
talk about them to other
professional scientists but hide them
from the public what should you do
the third thing we're going to talk
about is the general idea of
alien civilization should we be looking
for them are they likely to be out there
what should humanity's attitude be
toward this idea that we are not alone
in our nearby universe
and finally we're going to talk about
the nature of science as it is being
done
right now we talked a little bit about
this in last week's podcast with frank
wilczak where frank
offered the opinion that a lot of his
theoretical physicists friends had
wandered a little bit away from data
avilobe has similar uh opinions you know
avi's have been a great
extremely respected and um successful
theoretical astrophysicist for a long
time
he's also not afraid of poking the
hornet's nest now and then
so avi has very strong opinions about
how science should be done how it is
being done
and we have a wonderful conversation
about that so whatever we might
eventually decide
about the nature of this particular
thing that flew through the solar system
i'm entirely on the side of the idea
that we should explore
the dramatic ideas and we should take
them seriously and if they're wrong
if we have good reason to believe that
they're very unlikely we can discard
them and get on with our lives
but as much as there is a bias towards
shiny objects right we're saying oh this
is a cool idea let's think about this
there's a countervailing bias especially
among professional scientists which say
look
we're bombarded with absurd scientific
nonsense
in the popular media all the time it's
our duty
to stamp it out and therefore we should
not
even give any attention to these wilder
ideas
but i think we should be honest about
how difficult it is to
really draw the distinction between an
interesting crazy idea
that is worth pursuing and something
should be dismissed out of hand so
that's one of the issues
very very much on the table for this
conversation uh i think you'll like it
let's go
[Music]
avila welcome to the mindscape podcast
thank you for having me
so we're going to get into some details
obviously you talk a lot in your book
about this
visitor we had from interstellar space
amumua
but i thought they'd be very useful to
sort of lay the groundwork
uh by letting the audience know a little
bit about
what sort of background beliefs
professional physicists and astronomers
bring to this kind of thing so just just
to let people know
would you agree with me that most
professional astronomers or
astrophysicists spend approximately zero
time
thinking about alien life elsewhere in
the universe
yes i agree and that's unfortunate yeah
so but you had even before this recent
thing you had started becoming
interested in it
right actually i worked mostly on
cosmology on the the first generation of
stars in the universe
and on black holes but in studying
cosmology
one of the interesting frontiers that i
helped develop
was imaging hydrogen in the infant
universe
based on the very faint radio emission
at 21 centimeter wavelength that it
produces
and for that purpose there were a number
of
observatories constructed on earth uh
whose goal was to detect
this low frequency radio emission from
the early universe and and then in 2007
during a lunch uh i uh
joked with matthias daldaria about the
fact that you know the biggest
obstacle to making these observations uh
is radio interference from radio
stations and tv stations on earth
and because they operate at similar
frequencies and so
uh if if that poses a challenge why
wouldn't the same observatories be used
to eavesdrop
on signals from alien civilizations
that are produced just by leakage of
radio and tv broadcast
and then we went so matthias said
why don't we check the numbers we we
checked the numbers and we found that
how to distances of tens of light years
we should be able with existing
observatories uh targeting cosmology we
should be able to detect
uh the radio signals from civilizations
like ours
and of course we started transmitting uh
about a century ago and that's an
interesting coincidence that we can
detect things
out to at the distance that our light
was traveled in the meantime
and so we might hear a response from
those distances
if there is anyone out there well that's
the thing i mean i think that uh
the part of what i want to get down here
is you know thinking like a good
bayesian what our priors should be what
our expectations
are uh so i know a lot of this is old
ground but let's talk about
what we expect uh i mean there's the
drake equation there's the fermi paradox
all that stuff
in your mind do you think that life is
ubiquitous throughout our galaxy or is
it rare
and how often do you think it might be
intelligent or otherwise or is it
just one of these things we have no idea
right
well science is about evidence that's
one thing that galileo taught us that
you know you can have a beautiful
philosophical ideas that
the we are at the center of the universe
that the sun moves around the earth
aristotle was a very wise person but he
was wrong
uh and galileo realized that and said
that to philosophers look through my
telescope and you will figure it out as
well
and they said no we know the answer
where you know the sun moves around the
earth and they put him in house arrest
uh that didn't change the fact that the
earth moves around the sun
so the bottom line is prejudice should
not guide us
evidence should and
we should the evidence or facts are
those things that do not go away
irrespective of what we think and that's
what science could be all about
collecting evidence without prejudice
now one thing
one piece of evidence that we collected
recently actually this year
is that sun-like stars have
a planet of the size of the earth uh in
their habitable zone
uh roughly half of in in half of the
cases
um you know and that means that the
the earth sun system is very common
you know there are billions of such
systems within the milky way galaxy and
you roll the dice of life so many times
uh it's very likely that we are not
special you know
and then one of the big questions asked
by uh fermi and rico fermi during a
lunch
as well in los angeles about
70 years ago was you know if there is
life out there where is everybody why
don't we hear from them
now to me that's not a serious concern
because
you know when a pedestrian goes on a
sidewalk
um the pedestrian doesn't check every
ant
that is under uh his or her feet you
know and
we might be so common that we are of no
interest to anyone
and moreover we might not be smart
enough to figure out
that there are signals out there our
instruments may not be sensitive enough
we are not using sophisticated enough
artificial intelligence to
analyze our data and so it's just like
having a fishing net
that has uh two big uh of holes in it so
that the fish go through the holes
um and so we um the the fact that we
can't detect them and and that they
don't show up on our planet
i don't think uh uh it makes
any difference uh we just need to search
with more sensitivity
if you look at the gravitational wave
surge for example ligo
for many years ligo did not detect
anything and then in 2015
it reached a threshold sensitivity and
suddenly
there was a flood of events and by now
we have more than 50 events then the
nobel prize was given
for the first one of black hole mergers
and then it just shows that once you
reach a threshold sensitivity
you can detect a lot of signals but
before you do that
you detect nothing yeah you know i have
sort of
conflicting impulses pulling me in in
different directions here on the one
hand
let's go with the one hand first uh the
version of the fermi paradox the idea
that
there's could be so many civilizations
out there why haven't we heard them yet
the version that i've always found most
compelling is the fun neumann replicator
version where jon von neumann suggested
that you could
imagine building a machine that would go
out into the universe
stop by different solar systems
replicate itself
and then send out multiple copies of
itself and if this happened even once
in the history of the galaxy you know
the galaxy doesn't take that long to
just fill up
with these replicated machines so that's
the kind of thing you might think
would be easy to find here in the solar
system do you put any credence in that
kind of argument
well it turns out that it's not so easy
to find because
you know right now with the pan star
survey
we can detect objects of order 100
meters
at the distance of order the earth sun
separation
because we monitor the sky with high
enough sensitivity
we couldn't have done that before and
that's why the first interstellar object
was discovered in 2017.
bigger objects are more more rare
and we have to wait longer before one of
them crosses these distances so we can
see it
and so it's not it depends how big these
phenomena objects are and um
if there are of order tens of meters or
or less then
it we would have a hard time seeing them
if they move very fast
also astronomers would dismiss them as
as
astronomical sources because they move
too fast across our sky
most of the time we look for rocks
within
the solar system that move at tens of
kilometers per second if something would
move at the speed of light across our
sky
i can guarantee that no astronomer will
pay serious attention to it
[Laughter]
right and so you so you think that maybe
you know we are
surrounded by at least some density of
these
replicating machines it's possible we
just haven't noticed them yet yeah
and i think what we should do is develop
better and
more sensitive instruments and analyze
the data without prejudice
i always remember when i was a postdoc
the the field of gravitational lensing
became very popular
and it turned out that
gravitational lenses were discovered
decades earlier
and if you go through the astrophysical
journal at images of
clusters of galaxies those images
included giant arcs
uh that were not interpreted nobody paid
attention to them people said oh maybe
it's scattered light we don't know what
it is
uh and so only when the field became
popular suddenly people realized oh you
know these ancient images included
already data that indicates that
gravitational lensing takes place
and i think it requires
us to be open-minded attentive to
anomalies
the most important thing is to pay
attention to anomalies
and not shove them under the rug of
conservatism
right because most of the time what
people say oh there is something unusual
let's not tell anyone let's just say
well
you know it's just noise or something
instead
as scientists we should recognize that
breakthroughs
and discoveries uh occur only when you
pay attention to anomalies
if you are not open to wonderful things
to new things
you will never discover them and so i
think it's a self-fulfilling prophecy by
the scientific mainstream
to basically say we don't want to
consider anomalies we don't want
to look at extraterrestrial
civilizations the possibility that
they might exist uh and and with that
state of mind
obviously we will never find evidence
for those things but but i think it's
arrogant on our behalf
to believe that we are special and
unique uh you know my daughters when
they were infants
they tended to think that they are the
center of the world
that everything focuses on them then
they went to the street and saw other
kids
and they got a better perspective so the
only way for us to mature
as a civilization is to find evidence
that we are not alone and only then
people will get the right perspective
now if scientists refuse to look through
the telescopes with that notion in mind
then we will never find it it's just
like the philosophers in the days of
galileo i don't think
you know we learned the lesson exercise
and working out are really important but
if you're like me
it can be problematic sometimes to stay
motivated or to try to do something a
little bit
more to push yourself a little bit
that's why it's so helpful to have an
instructor or a trainer
but at home that's hard to do
fortunately peloton is to the rescue
with world-class instructors curated
music and endless fitness variety
peloton has created an unmatched fitness
experience to help keep you motivated
and focused workout after workout and
peloton isn't just
game changing cardio you can add a
strength class to your ride
or combine cardio and strength in one
workout with bike boot camp
to get a total body fitness experience
from beginner programs to tabata
intervals
peloton meets you at every step in your
fitness journey as you progress
choose from a wide range of cycling
classes that meet your level and keep
you challenged every time you clip in
so get started on your peloton journey
today and download the peloton app
before january 31st 2021 for a two month
free trial
that's two free months when you download
the peloton app on your phone tablet or
smart tv this is a
that's a huge set of questions here uh
that i do want to get to
later in the podcast but it would
distract us from
extraterrestrial life and intelligent
civilization so let's let's footnote
that
for right now bracket it off because i
want to i talk about
this idea of the probes one more time
because there's the idea of probes that
just sort of
zip by and we can't notice them but it's
also
someone pointed out to me um that you
know if you think about
listening for communications from
extraterrestrials by radio waves or
something like that
that sounds like a huge long shot just
because
you need to be listening to them at
exactly the right time
that they would be giving out those
radio waves and maybe most civilizations
are not as
wasteful as us just beaming stuff out
into the sky
it might be better to imagine that if
other civilizations
wanted to make contact with us they
would send
a kind of probe to come to the solar
system and stay here
either in orbit around somewhere or
landing on a planet you know like a
monolith kind of hypothesis a la 2001
uh because then you can integrate over
time and you can just be ready for
whenever
the local life forms are ready to talk
to you yeah that's an excellent point
but
i i don't think that we are sufficiently
interesting for them to pay attention to
us
that's one thing i wanted to mention
because probably
we are our form of life is quite common
uh the conditions that we have on earth
are reproduced in so many other places
that there is no reason for me to expect
us to be
you know the sharpest cookie in the jar
not only that we are common but we are
not really
necessarily particularly intelligent or
interesting
you know when you look at recipe books
you can make many different cakes out of
the same ingredients
and so the ingredients on earth the
chemical soup that was on earth early on
made life as we know it and and us
but i'm sure we are not the most
tasty cake that one can imagine out of
the same ingredients you can have
much more sophisticated cakes much more
advanced civilizations
also that existed for longer than us and
therefore have
more advanced technologies and why would
they be interested in us in any way
but the other thing i wanted to
reinforce is your point of view that
uh if you look at us the way we behave
we are not
doing the best things that would
guarantee our survival in the long term
we are by developing our technologies we
develop the means for our own
destruction
and the same could happen for another
civilization and
it's possible that technological
civilizations are short-lived
because of the of the fact that they
change the climate
uh on their planet or they go into wars
with each other or all kinds of other
reasons and
uh if if that is the case most of the
time you will find
dead civilizations if you were to look
at the sky and
you might think oh well then i cannot
establish
any evidence for for their existence
that's not true
because on earth there used to be
cultures that disappeared
and we find them through archaeology we
dig into the ground and we find
relics that they left behind and the
same thing we can do in space we can do
space archaeology
and find for example burnt up surfaces
of planets
industrial pollution of atmospheres of
planets
where the industries that polluted the
atmosphere
are not around anymore but the molecules
that they produced are still around
we can find the photovoltaic cells
coating planets for example if they have
a permanent dayside they might want to
use the light on that permanent day side
to illuminate the dark side and the the
civilization may be dead by now but we
can find evidence for photovoltaic cells
from the reflectivity of the surface
from uh
the reflectivity as a function of
wavelength there would be an edge
photovoltaic cells have a spectral edge
in their reflectance
and so you know there are various ways
by which we can find evidence
mega structures that are left behind and
then i think we should search
the key is not to believe that you know
the answer in advance
sure that's the lesson from galileo yeah
but i mean
of course i i'm i do want to talk about
this later and i'm torn between the idea
that yes we should absolutely search and
you know it would be one of the most
groundbreaking
world-changing discoveries of all time
where we to discover an extraterrestrial
civilization
and at the same time we have to be able
to distinguish between
you know hypotheses that have a one
percent chance of being right and
hypotheses that have a 10 to the minus
10
chance of being right those are those
are very different things that we should
act about them
differently right you would agree yeah
and then but we do have one data point
here
and that is that we exist and that we
have life on earth okay
and then the second data point is that
earth is not rare
uh in fact you find a lot of planets the
size of the earth
at the right distance from their host
star to have liquid water on the surface
and potentially the chemistry of life as
we know it so
these two facts combined to me indicate
that
we're probably not alone that at least
you know as a matter of the scientific
uh inquiry of what exists out there you
know right now if you look at astronomy
it's all focused on
uh physical objects right we're talking
about the cosmic microwave background
uh we are talking about planets uh we
are talking about
stars all physical objects we don't
think about biological
entities out there and in fact they may
be very prevalent it's just that the
signals associated with them are weak
it's not easy to find primitive life you
know you could
you could search for oxygen and methane
in the atmospheres of planet it's not
easy
the signals of a spaceship uh
you know are very faint i i did the
calculation no telescope on earth can
detect even
a giant spaceship at the edge of the
solar system you know
the city of just to give you an example
uh the city of tokyo
uh if you uh put it on pluto
um then that will be at the limit of the
hubble space telescope
if it integrates for a few weeks it
would be able to see it
uh so you know it's really challenging
uh to see uh evidence for life at great
distances and given that and given the
fact that we exist here and the
conditions are replicated in so many
other places
uh i would say that it's very likely
that we are not alone it's just that
it's challenging to find evidence for
that yeah i mean i have to push back
against this a little bit just because
there's a little bit of a leap
from there are many many planets out
there many of them
undoubtedly uh habitable in some broad
classification by how we would think
about it
um but then you're multiplying that big
number all of the drake equation by
the fraction of planets on which number
one life's come to
comes to exist number two it becomes
complicated and multicellular
and number three it becomes
technological number four it still
survives if it's still surviving now
you know personally i i'm very happy to
accept the idea that maybe
uh the galaxy is full of life but i'm
also perfectly happy to exit to imagine
that
life doesn't uh very often come into
existence or when it does it just
remains unicellular
well i call it the principle of cosmic
modesty
i'm you know i i just believe in modesty
being humble and not believing that one
is special because most of the time when
you feel that you're special you're
proven wrong
okay and so
my my tendency is to have a
based on my experience in life to to
adapt the modesty also with respect to
the cosmos and not assume
arrogantly that we are special or unique
uh that's a matter of preference you
know
a lot of people prefer to believe that
they're special and unique
and and you know i know of many people
that believe
so much in that notion that they never
find a date
you know when they go on dates they
never find a mate someone that they can
live with
because they feel that they are so
special you know if we
uh adapt this uh notion we and we don't
even
search we don't go on a date you know we
don't even check if there are out
if there is anyone out there you know we
will live in ignorance and
that's what i hate to see that not
collecting data because of
a wrong prejudice is really a terrible
sin
uh for scientists uh i think scientists
should
look for all the possible evidence
without prejudice
sure no i'm 100 in in favor of
collecting the evidence but
i i do think that we need to imagine you
know establishing some credence so we
can
uh figure out how much effort we should
put into collecting
this evidence and i i mean i have to
confess i'm extremely suspicious
of the we are not special argument
because if you say well i'm going to be
modest and assume that
i'm just a typical non-special person in
the universe
that's not really very modest at all you
can flip that around by saying
i assume that the universe is like it is
here
which is actually not very uh humble
it's pretty
presumptuous i just don't i like to just
not
quite draw the conclusion i like to say
like well you know let's be open-minded
about this i i should say
this is not um a proposal for for a
thesis this is just a working
uh assumption that allows me to
go out without a prejudice into the
world and
examine the evidence so what i'm just
asking is
to not to block uh the pursuit of
evidence so
for example just to give you an example
right now um
the mainstream of astronomy because we
detected so many exoplanets
uh the mainstream is uh advocating the
construction of major telescopes major
observatories that will cost hundreds of
millions or even billions of dollars
to search for oxygen and methane in the
atmospheres of planets
and at best that would indicate
primitive life
microbial life there is zero
dollars allocated in those plans
for the search for intelligent life now
when phosphine was reported on in the
cloud deck of venus
uh scientists mainstream scientists
argued well you know phosphine indeed is
the result of life on earth but
on venus maybe it's volcanic maybe it's
something else
um we don't believe it it's necessarily
implying
life so i asked the same mainstream
astronomers how dare you advocate that
detecting oxygen would be indicative of
life when you dismiss
phosphine as an indicator of life now
if oxygen can be produced by breaking
water
and by other natural processes why would
that
say anything about microbial life now
what you ask yourself so what kind of
molecules would convince everyone
that there is life i would say cfcs
those
uh industrial pollutants that we
produced
in coolants and the industries that
that cannot be produced by nature these
are molecules that are extremely complex
so if we search for
signatures of molecules in the
atmospheres of planets
why don't we search for cfcs as much as
we search for oxygen
i would say that could be a good
argument for building these
observatories
because everyone would agree if we
detect cfcs on another planet
everyone would agree that it's very
difficult to make such molecules
by natural processes yeah i mean i think
that uh i i and again
all all the arguments that you have to
say that we should go out there and look
i'm
entirely on board with um and it's
interesting
i mean maybe let's just delve into the
psychology of this because i do also
agree with you
that if you say well let's go look for
this or that molecule
maybe as an indication of primitive life
astronomers and scientists get very
excited
and as soon as you say well let's look
for evidence for
technological civilizations they get
nervous
right i mean what is the psychology
behind that is it is it that they worry
that they won't be taken seriously
if they act to science fictiony well
right now
it's um social pressure and the bullying
and
you know and and herd mentality but if
you ask yourself why did it get to this
point
uh there is a long tradition of science
fiction
and the uh reports without the
uh scientific critics for uh
unidentified the
flying objects ufos these these reports
are not reproducible they are not
standing up to the scrutiny of
scientific evidence
you know they were taken they were
fastly 50 years ago with the cameras
that existed back then and now we have
much better cameras
and they're all also fuzzy so
fast that tells you that something is
wrong with these reports because we
develop much better instrumentation to
detect the unusual
phenomenon and and these are always
on the borderline of believability you
know the ufo reports
so given this background and also given
the fact that
a lot of our colleagues uh get um
a a boost to their ego if they belong to
an elite
uh club they were they do not
necessarily pay attention to what the
public is interested in but
they elevate themselves to discussions
on you know
how many engines can can stand on on on
a pin
okay or or in other words
issues related with uh anti-deceiter
space that
does not represent uh reality or
issues related with extra dimensions to
which we haven't found
any evidence yet that is considered
mainstream you know in theoretical
physics
i do know however it's of little
interest to the public
and elevating yourself to do
intellectual gymnastics
just to impress your peers
just to gain honors awards and to show
that you are smart
that's very much of the academic game
rather than
you know echoing interest of the public
and i think it's a self-inflicted wound
that that academia is considered part of
the elite because
uh you know it's also for the scientists
to blame that they are not paying
attention to what the public is
interested in
and we have the technology to address
the question of whether
other intelligent life exists out there
it's just that we choose not to use this
technology in that
to answer this question we choose not to
invest funding
even at the 10 level in uh search for
techno signatures
whereas the the rest you know much
more funds are allocated to the search
for biosignatures and
i think it's a matter of choice it's not
a matter of reason
and my my goal in in
writing this book and also i have a
textbook coming out
in in june 2021 800 pages long about the
search for both intelligent
and primitive life with manasvillinga my
former postdoc
my goal is to bring it to the mainstream
yeah no i'm now i'm completely on board
in the message and it's weird and it's
hard to
it's hard to analyze the biases of the
academic community
in an objective way because you know who
who has the perspective of being
completely unbiased but i do think that
there is a certain stuffiness a certain
insularity
that marks certain pursuits as not
academically respectable and others as
uh perfectly okay and so
that's one of the reasons why i wanted
to invite you on the podcast i'm a
little skeptical about
muammua but i'm very much enthusiastic
about
pursuing this as a serious intellectual
let me give you another example that i
actually uh was involved in and that is
cosmic inflation so
i i was in a debate with alan guth in
which
alan basically said that
it's a silly question to ask whether
inflation is falsifiable
uh that in fact it's a it's a framework
that cannot be falsified that whatever
data we collect about
cosmology about the universe can be
accommodated in some version
of or some model of inflation cosmic
inflation
now that is allowed that is part of the
mainstream and alan guth represents
a cosmic inflation that is very widely
accepted
however people would say
the possibility that the signal that we
detected is artificial
should not be considered because an
artificial origin
could explain almost everything like
pulsars
uh others you know other unusual
phenomena
so i would say there is a lack of
intellectual honesty
in for example treating something like
inflation or extra dimensions
or even some you know proposals for the
dark matter
you know we we invested hundreds of
millions of dollars searching for the
dark matter
and many of these searches failed uh
we we believe that it's not the all the
weekly interacting massive particles
that parameter space is ruled out
but nobody complains of course um you
know it was worth
checking if that idea bears any fruit so
the dark matter is not
the traditional weekly interacting
massive particles that's good to know
but at the same time people say why
should we spend money on searching for
other civilizations if we um
know that the the we might not find
anything
well we do the same thing in many other
aspects of science we search for things
and we are not guaranteed to find an
answer
i think there's still some parameter
space left for weekly interacting
massive particles
but let's not get into that that's a
that's a different podcast but
i also want to uh just emphasize one
point that you you know you made and it
went by pretty quickly which is that
when you are thinking about looking for
evidence for
uh extraterrestrial civilizations
advanced uh life forms elsewhere
you are not thinking about you know the
cia
uh releasing some fuzzy videos we're
we're recording this we should we should
tell people
a couple of days after uh a retired
israeli general
says oh yeah we're totally talking to
the galactic federation the the israeli
and u.s governments have just hushed it
up
you are not talking about that not at
all i think this this is complete
nonsense
um i think our governments are not
sufficiently competent to hide
such an important revelation um and
uh obviously if we had conclusive
evidence for anything
we you know everyone would know about
yeah yeah okay
and but and then the final thing before
we get on to the details of your book
this has too many things to talk about
here
um you mentioned the fact that you know
some of these um
civilizations could be archaeological
finds they could have gone away and we
could find their remnants
but let's just get the time scales into
people's brains here
if they don't go away then we would
expect that a
typical galactic technological
civilization
would be millions if not billions of
years more advanced than us right
that's right and and and that is quite
interesting because
if you look at our technologies they are
evolving exponentially
right now on a few year time scale so
just imagine
i mean we cannot really imagine what our
technologies would look like a hundred
years from now
but giving it them a thousand years a
million years or a billion years
basically it would look like magic to us
we would see things
uh that look like miracles that that we
cannot really understand
well it's it creates a dilemma for those
of us who would want to
you know do science on this which is
it's hard to know even what we would be
looking for right
exactly so what um often you do
um you know if you never met the
people and um you you you're about to
meet
the first people then you look at the
mirror and
and say well maybe they look just like
me uh
and and then um it it works
actually they look similar to you as
long as you have a common
genetic heritage you know that you were
connected
but when you deal with life that formed
on completely disconnected planets
that is not guaranteed at all uh you
know the grass on
proxima centauri b might not be green
because that star is producing
infrared light it's not producing
visible light so
just think and obviously if there are
animals on the permanent day side
they have infrared eyes that look very
different
than our eyes and so just imagining the
same
uh of you know this the same
more of the same is is the wrong and i
think
the wrong approach and i think we will
be shocked both if
uh if we were to to meet life uh on
from another planetary system uh or if
we were to
to meet uh the technologies that emerged
on a more mature civilizations
than ours and um so we are out to to a
shock
uh uh and and of course that that could
be one reason why we haven't seen it yet
because
we're not looking at the right places
even for someone who writes all the time
certain writing projects are a little
bit more
challenging than others maybe you're
writing an email to your landlord a note
to your boss or a long message to a
friend
grammarly premium might be the solution
grammarly premium gives you real
time feedback and insights to help you
elevate your writing
through tone word choice clarity and
more
if you do write a lot you can find
yourself falling into traps falling into
repetitive things you do over and over
again grammarly premium helps you
tighten up your prose make things more
clear
make you come through more concisely and
crisply by cutting out unnecessary words
and redundant words
vary up your vocabulary by avoiding
overused words
so elevate your writing with 20 off
grammarly premium
by signing up at grammarly.com mindscape
that's 20 off grammarly premium at
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash mindscape
yeah i mean one of the possibilities for
why we haven't seen extraterrestrial
life yet uh even if it is ubiquitous in
the universe is the idea that
uh we can upload ourselves our
consciousnesses our brain states into
computers at some point
and right now we embodied biological
organisms are
driven by all of these impetuses and
instincts that are given to us by
evolution to survive to eat to reproduce
to learn
but maybe when we upload ourselves sort
of that biology goes away
and those motivations go away and people
just sort of lose interest
in exploring the rest of the universe
what do you think about that one
yeah that's that's quite possible and i
think very advanced
civilizations might develop social
distancing
on a cosmic scale they might create
their own cocoons
and then basically close themselves off
and not interact with anyone because
they have a
very comfortable habitat that they
created
and they don't need anyone now that
doesn't mean that we cannot detect
them they always need to produce trash
because
of the second law of thermodynamics so
just like investigative
journalists that going to the trash cans
of
hollywood celebrities we might be able
to learn something about them
by looking at their trash but it's quite
possible that
they have no interest in establishing
contact
now i should mention to you an anecdote
um uh you know one of the biggest
puzzles in um in cosmology is what
happened before the big bang
okay what started uh the universe
and um uh i have one
possible solution for that um you know
suppose we
develop theory of quantum gravity and
the which we don't have right now and we
understand how the universe started okay
and we realized that we can actually
produce a baby universe in the
laboratory
suppose we realize that then
there is a solution to what happened
before the big bang and the solution is
that the universe like ours produces a
civilization like
ours that gets to be intelligent enough
to figure out
how to make a baby universe and then a
new
a new universe comes out of us uh
and that will allow another civilization
inside of it to create another universe
and so forth
and if we were to ask where did we come
from
it will be from a laboratory of a
previous species
that created our universe i like that
idea it's very similar to a
paper that i actually published uh but
it was a we had a natural way of making
baby universes they were not
artificially created in the lab but
the spirit of it is very much the same
and to be fair we should give credit to
alan guth who was one of the first
people to
show us how to build a baby university
laboratory definitely he did
very important work it's just that i do
not agree with some of the premises in
his late life
sure okay so finally 2017
we got a visitor from outer space why
don't you tell us a little bit about
that
yes on october 19th 2017 the
uh panstarrs observatory on mount
haleakala
in maui hawaii discovered
the first object near the earth that
came from outside
the solar system and we could tell
because it moved too fast
to be bound to the sun and
they gave it the name omumua which means
scout in hawaii
interestingly by coincidence i visited
just a few months earlier um and
at that time omuamua was approaching the
earth
rather than moving away from the earth
it was discovered
once it started running away from us at
a very high speed
that no rocket that we have built in the
past could have
caught up with it but if we would have
known about it when i visited
in july 2017 then we could have designed
a space
mission that would meet it halfway and
take a photograph
but anyway uh the immediate reaction of
the astronomy community was
oh great we have an interstellar object
uh
it's probably either a comet or an
asteroid and
most likely a comet because comets are
icy
rocks that many of which can originate
from the outermost
part of the solar system the oort cloud
and so if other
uh stars have an oort cloud uh
these are objects that are loosely bound
and can easily be torn apart from their
host
star and and so most of the time you
will get
an icy rock coming from interstellar
space that would look like a comet with
a cometary tail
right unfortunately omumua did not show
a cometary tail
uh it it looked
as if it's just maybe just a rock so
people said well okay so then it's an
asteroid
but then when they monitor the light
from it the light
changed at the brightness of the object
which is just reflected sunlight
uh changed by a factor of 10 as it
tumbled and that means that the area of
the object on the sky that reflects
sunlight changes by a factor of 10 as it
spins around
and that is very extreme we have not
seen
something like that before in the solar
system
and it means that the object has an
extreme geometry
uh and if you try to fit the light curve
it turns out that at the 90
confidence you can show that it should
be flattened
not elongated not cigar shaped but
rather
pancake shaped so that's another
peculiar fact about this object that
became clear
and and the more we learned about it the
more peculiar it became
and then in may 2018
there was a paper published saying that
this object
exhibited an excess push away from the
sun
that uh beyond the the gravity of the
sun
and such a push can be obtained for
example from the rocket effect
on a comet when the ice on the surface
of the comet evaporates it pushes the
comet
in the opposite direction right but
there was no cometary tail and
the spitzer space telescope looked very
um
carefully at this the environment of
this object and didn't detect any
carbon-based molecules
or dust or anything that makes cometary
tails usually
uh and then so that was a puzzle what is
pushing this object
so i i wrote a scientific american essay
in which
i said maybe it's an artificial object
and then i
i wrote another more extensive paper
mentioning all the peculiarities there
were six of them
uh of this object it it also originated
in a very special frame of reference
which is
um the the i call it the galactic
parking lot
where you know if you place your car
there nobody know would know where the
car came from
so this is called the local standard of
rest
um so it's the frame of reference that
is obtained from averaging the motion of
all the stars in the vicinity of the sun
and uh it was at rest in that frame
just like a beauty on the surface of an
ocean and the sun
or the solar system collided with it
because of its motion relative to that
frame
only one in 500 stars is so much at rest
in that frame as umuah was it was not
moving at all
in our local frame uh and then we bumped
into it like a ship
bumping into a bui and so there were a
number of these very strange
facts about umuah and over the summer of
2018 i
i realized well you know maybe it's
artificial maybe
and then at the same time i um had a new
postdoc
join my group uh shmuel bialy and i
suggested to him
that perhaps this push that the object
exhibited
is as a result of sunlight bouncing off
the surface of this object and in order
for that to be effective you need the
object to have a large surface area
for its weight sure and we figured out
that
a solar sail a light sail
would do it uh if it has a thickness of
less than a millimeter
and so we published we submitted the
paper to the astrophysical journal
letters
it was accepted within a few days there
were three actually
said that you know that actually there
is
uh supporting evidence that this object
appears to be
most likely flat rather than elongated
and and that supports your your idea and
so
and and that that's it i didn't we
didn't have a press
release or anything but then a couple of
bloggers
uh wrote about it and the subject became
viral
uh to my surprise i should say because
you know just a year before that
uh i i wrote a paper suggesting that the
dark matter maybe
may have an electric charge a very small
electric charge
and to me that's a bigger speculation
and no
nobody com you know paid
too much attention to that even though
it was published in a prestigious
journal
uh so so then of course there was a lot
of
response from both the public and the
scientific community to this this
this idea um but what i would like to
mention is an anecdote that
just this year uh in september 2020
uh there was another object discovered
that was not identified there was no
cometary tale
but this object seemed to move in an
orbit similar to that of the earth
and it was given the name 2020
so discovered in september 2020
and then
the astronomers integrated the orbit of
this object back in time
and found that it must have
coincided with the earth in 1966
and it turns out that in 1966 there was
a failed mission called the surveyor ii
moonlander and the uh
booster of that rocket uh was kicked
into space
and most likely that is what we've seen
as 20 20 so
and clearly an artificially made object
and it was hollow and
they found that there is evidence from
its orbit
actually for a deviation as a result
of the push by sunlight right
and they wrote about in it's in today's
new york times
science section it says uh there is
evidence that the sun
pushes this object and that's evidence
that it is hollow
and um you know that's interesting
because we are able to recognize the
artificial objects
like 20 20 so based on their orbit and
the fact that they don't show a cometary
tale
and to me it reminded of umuah except
umu was not produced by us
so um and and the other thing i wanted
to mention is
you know when when i go on vacation i
often
like to be close to a beach and i i
uh look at the seashells on the on the
surface of the beach
um and the seashells are naturally
produced an issue for them looks
different from the others and
[Music]
but every now and then i encounter a
plastic bottle
that is artificially made and it's
clear that uh that there was a
civilization that produced this plastic
bottle so
so perhaps uh is a message in a bottle
from another civilization if it is a
light sale and and that's a hypothesis
that
that we can falsify by um
looking for additional objects similar
to it
in the future yeah no i think it's
definitely one worth taking seriously so
let's just because a lot of the
listeners are not going to be experts in
the techniques of modern astrophysics
let's
let's talk first about you know how
astronomers
uh tackle something like this i mean we
have telescopes and
we pointed at it but we don't have an
image of what the thing looked like
right we tried we tried to look for that
commentary tale
but it's just too small and faint is
that right that's right it's point like
the only way to get an image is to get
close enough to it
and that is possible if the object for
example is approaching us
uh because you don't need to move very
fast you just meet it
um and so hopefully next time around if
we see an object as
weird as we will see it when it's
approaching us
and it came you were sort of remarkably
close to the sun it was inside the orbit
of mercury and maybe that's a selection
effect that
if it had not passed within the orbit of
mars then it just never would have even
been noticed
yeah it was noticed on its way out but
it definitely had to come
very close to the earth within the earth
sun separation for us to notice it
and with with pan stars and before pan
stars we just didn't have the
instruments that would allow us
to detect such objects and you know so
it's
it's clear now the other thing i wanted
to mention is
a decade ago we wrote a paper with amaya
moro martin and ed turner
forecasting how many interstellar
objects we should expect
and whether pan stars should see any of
them and we concluded no if we
if we just make a forecast based on what
we know about the solar system and the
rocks that exist
in the solar system that could have been
ejected over the lifetime of the solar
system
we predicted an abundance of objects
that is
short by a factor of a hundred to a
hundred million
than the population needed to explain
omuamua
so the mere detection of this object is
by itself a surprise
right and you did say about the inferred
shape of it so talk talk to me more
because this is i was an undergraduate
astronomy major and even a graduate
student although i don't do astronomy in
any real sense but
i've always been enormously impressed by
the ability of astronomers to take
these little fragments of data like a
light curve
and spin a rather elaborate tale about
what we can learn so
where do you get information about is it
elongated or pancake shaped or anything
like that
yeah so this is based on the amount of
light that is reflected
as a function of time uh so the object
you see so let's imagine that we can
resolve it
so basically there is a certain surface
area that it occupies on the sky
it occupies a certain area and the sun
reflects
of the object we can think for example
on satellites okay so suppose we look at
communication satellites
you know when they pass over the sky uh
and by the way that's a problem for
astronomy in the future there will be
yes tens of thousands of them uh that
are planned for launch by
spacex and other companies and that
would pose a problem for
the vera rubin observatory but they the
point is
whenever sunlight reflects off them we
can
detect the amount of light that we
receive and even if we don't resolve the
object we see how much
how much light we get and then from this
point of light
and the amount of light that we get uh
changes in time because
either the object changes its
orientation relative to us
or because it spins you know it tumbles
um yeah so
most of the rocks do not maintain
the same face in in our direction
because they spin and um was spinning
with a period of eight hours so every
eight hours
its brightness went from up down and
then up again so that was a full period
of them and then we can monitor how much
light we get
when you know it reflects the most
amount of light versus when
it's dimmer because it shows a smaller
surface to us
and so if you imagine um a pancake like
object
the change in the amount of light that
you get as the object is spinning
would be different than if you were to
have
a cigar-shaped object spinning and so
you can try and model it
it's now the the one thing that you
don't know is the reflectivity of the
surface
you know potentially there are spots on
the surface that are more reflected
reflective than other parts and that's
something we don't know but
if you assume let's say a uniform
reflectance
then it's very easy to try and constrain
the geometry of the object
from the the light curve because we know
where the sun is located
we know that where the object is located
in its orbit
around the sun and we can try and model
that
it's not too complicated i think even a
high schooler can do it
and is the consensus that it is more
likely pancake shape than cigar shape
yeah there was a paper that did the
analysis in great detail
um just a year ago and uh by machenko
sergey machenko and
uh demonstrated that and argued that at
the 90 percent confidence level
uh it's uh pancake shape before that
there was also the argument that
uh if you wanted to fit the light curve
it turns out that the object with
um the most amount of um
random motion internal
motions um uh so if if you imagine um
being kicked around
by all kinds of objects obstacles along
the
path of its trajectory then you would
expect it to occupy the highest
energy state that it can get and the
highest energy state for it would be
associated with a pancake
a cigar shape would be associated with
the least
the lowest energy state and that's less
likely
so that argument was already made early
on with the detection of umumua
but what was done later with with all
the data that was collected
was to try and model the light curve and
that by mashchenko
argued that it at the 90 percent
confidence is
its pancake shape do we have any idea of
what its mass is
so the mass depends on uh the geometry
so if you imagine
the it being even razor thin like a
light sail we were talking about
uh it's very unlikely that it would be
edge-on
uh when we look at it right so a change
by a factor of 10 can apply also to a
very thin
object we just don't know how thick it
is
and the amount of mass that it carries
depends on how thick it is
all we know is that one projected on the
sky
as it spins around the area of the
object
changes by a factor of 10. um yeah and
um the amount of mass i should say if
you were to assume that it's a rock
uh you know with a characteristic
density of a rock
and dimensions of let's say 100 meters
in length
and 10 meters in width
um then you would get
something that is uh from the the fact
that it's a member of a population
of objects of similar properties you
would get
that you cannot easily explain its
existence with what we know about
planetary systems we are off by orders
of magnitude it's just
difficult to produce you need a
quadrillion
such objects produced per star
and the amount of mass that each of them
carries makes it quite difficult to
explain and
um amaya mauro martin wrote a couple of
papers on that how difficult it is to
produce
if it's a rock so many of them so that
we will see one
within a few years with pan stars
however if you make it like a light sail
it doesn't carry as much weight
uh actually uh it could be um
the quadrillion such objects would be uh
would carry
the mass of an asteroid that has a size
of of roughly
a kilometer or so uh so so
in principle there will not be a a lot
of mass associated with umumua
if it's very thin yeah so in the
interest of still
normalizing the expectations uh for what
kinds of things might be out there for
our audience you know astronomers have
thought about this a lot but maybe the
people on the street haven't
you've you've mentioned rocks uh and you
mentioned comets and so
those are a little bit different right
rocks are solid and comets are
made of ice or other volatile things
that can
uh light up when they come near the sun
and maybe there's some sort of
in-between thing where there's a loose
agglomeration of rocky
and icy things and we we think that
all these things are in our solar system
right we we find them but the
the oort cloud and maybe the kuiper belt
very far away
are more icy more rocky what more
stuff do we use the story actually since
you um did your phd at harvard i should
mention the story starts with fred
whipple that used to be at harvard and
i think he got the idea it wasn't clear
at his time what
these comets are um and
he came after going through harvard yard
during a snowstorm he came up with the
idea that
you know they might be uh dirty ice
um uh or uh it turns out that
they're more more likely i see dirt
so in other words it's mostly a rock i
mean comets are mostly a rock and and
they have
some uh water ice on them
now one thing about water ice to keep in
mind is um
it doesn't go to liquid uh if you warm
it up
uh in space uh in order for water to go
to liquid as we find the
on earth you need an atmosphere you need
an external pressure
and that doesn't exist on a small rock
uh in space and so if you warm it up
when the rock
gets close to the sun the ice go
sublimates directly into gas and that's
what we see as the cometary tail
we see the gas that is created by
warming up the ice
and then and so the the so the solar
system had
um basically um the debris that was left
over from the formation of the sun
created this protoplanetary disk a disk
of material that was orbiting the sun
and the small dust particles collided to
make
bigger and bigger rocks and beyond a
certain distance from the sun there was
ice water ice because it was too
cold in that disc and water could not
exist in gas form so it
solidified into ice and that's how you
get these
uh icy rocks in the outer part of the
solar system where
the conditions were cold enough for them
to form and these are relics of
the formation of the solar system you
have all these uh
rocks moving around and some of them
were kicked by planets and
occupy the the oort cloud and some of
them were
you know donated to our solar system
from other
stars as well so they are orbiting uh
the sun at great distances that go out
to a hundred thousand times the earth
sun separation
and whenever one of them passes close to
the sun we see it as a comet
and every now and then we also get some
objects to collide with the earth
uh that's what killed the dinosaurs you
know unfortunately the dinosaurs didn't
have
a science and astronomy so they they
couldn't have
studied the sky and and
and as a result they saw this giant rock
heading their way and they couldn't do
anything about it
hopefully you know we by pan stars by
monitoring the sky can alert us
to any dangerous rock that is heading
our way and perhaps we can
um give it a nudge so that it will not
hit the earth
here in our solar system then you know
we have these rocky things and these
snowballs these comets and presumably
some of them are kicked out of the solar
system right from either
random jigglings due to planets or maybe
in other circumstances there could be
explosions or collisions so
therefore we would expect some flux of
interstellar visitors here visiting us
right
definitely in fact the or cloud extends
halfway
to the nearest star the alpha centauri
system
and those old clouds if each star has an
odd cloud around it you can think of
them as
billiard balls that are touching each
other so space is full of these
uh or clouds and it's easy for a star
to pass near an old cloud of another
star
and tear it apart basically get some
objects
kicked out um and therefore the
interstellar
space is full of of objects and
it should not be a surprise that some of
them enter the solar system
and that's what we calculated the a
decade ago but we just didn't expect an
abundance so large
as to explain uh or more like object
because
what we calculated is the natural
density or abundance of such objects
is not high enough for pan stars to
detect any of them
but apparently it did i should say there
was a second object interstellar object
detected and
that is by an amateur russian astronomer
called
gennady borisov and he built a telescope
and detected
what looked like a regular comet that is
not bound to the sun
and then people came to me and said well
this one
looks just like a regular comet this
interstellar object
doesn't it convince you that omomua was
also natural
and my answer to that was you know when
i went on a date the first date with my
wife
she did look special to me and the fact
that i met many other people afterwards
didn't change that opinion so the fact
that
we saw borisov looking like a typical
comment
didn't make omua muah more typical
i guess the thing that is most
provocative about amumua is
the combination of the fact that on the
one hand it did
accelerate right i mean there was some
non-gravitational push which by itself
is not surprising because comets do that
when
gases light up and and and push away
but on the other hand we didn't see any
such outgassing is that right is that
the real tension that we're working to
so that's the main that's the main
peculiarity that
that it exhibited an extra push uh
without
um a cometary tail and and that led the
few
mainstream astronomers to come up with
innovative
ideas for example maybe it's a hydrogen
iceberg
something that we have never seen before
the problem with that and we wrote a
paper about this
with theme huang showing that a hydrogen
iceberg
would not survive the journey it would
evaporate
over the millions of years that it takes
it to to reach us
from a distant molecular cloud
and the reason that the hydrogen iceberg
was proposed is because in that case you
would not see
a regular cometary tail
it would be made of hydrogen that is
invisible an invisible gas and
and also it would give because it's so
light it would give more of a push
but i don't think well first of all
hydrogen icebergs were never seen
but moreover uh we have good theoretical
reasons not to expect them to exist
and then another idea was maybe it's a
dust bunny
you know the kind of things you find at
home when you don't clean
uh home very often
and the idea there is that maybe it's an
object that is a hundred times less
dense than air
uh so it's very fluffy and porous
and that kind of an object can be pushed
by sunlight
so it doesn't need to be a light sail
sure it could be a dust bunny here again
i have a problem with its
survival over millions of years in the
intestinal medium i just
have a hard time imagining a dust bunny
of the size of a football field
spinning around uh every eight hours
and surviving a journey of millions of
years
you know it's just less plausible to me
but i should say that
you know while people were coming with
these challenging scenarios and these
are people from the mainstream
other people from the mainstream were
arguing forget about it it's natural and
that's it end of argument
there is nothing to discuss and i find
this to be a very strange situation
where
some people have a hard time explaining
the facts that we know
and others are claiming forget about the
fact let's move on business is fusion
yeah so i mean the nice thing about the
light sail hypothesis
is that it would be something which
would be big and flat
uh very very thin but also robust
against us surviving for a long time in
interstellar space exactly that's one
thing we checked in the paper
that was the first thing we checked they
will it survive all the dust that is
bumping against it and the interstellar
medium the radiation so forth
and we find that found that there
shouldn't be any problem
um so i mean this is a falsifiable
unlike inflation it's falsifiable a
falsifiable hypothesis
in the sense that you know we just need
to find another object
that shows similar properties and then
you know take a photograph of it or
or just get more data on it i'm just
proposing this
conjecture as a testable hypothesis
and there is nothing different from
suggesting this is nothing different
from suggesting that the dark matter has
a small electric charge that you can
test in the laboratory in principle or
or any other scientific inquiry and it's
only the emotional uh blockage or
the taboo that is put by the scientific
community that prevents us from going in
these directions right now
my impression is that the biggest
challenge to the light sail idea
is the tumbling uh you wouldn't quite
expect a light sail to tumble in the
exact way that this one does but am i
right about that or did i make it if
it's
yes you're right if it's functional if
it's something that was designed
to to maintain its integrity in a way
that
that you know it's operational right now
but if it's um
you know just a piece of equipment that
is defunct by now
um or or serve some other purpose i'm
not sure
you know we this is guess work the
question is what really physically
speaking you know what
is this what is this object what's the
geometry what is it made of
um is it shiny it's just a shiny rock or
is it
shiny because it's made of metal you
know that that's a simple question
um it turns out that spitzer the special
space telescope did not detect any
heat coming from it and given the amount
of sunlight that we
that it reflected it looks like it it
was
more shiny than average an average uh
asteroid or comet so so it's just
a very simple question what is it made
of how does it look
and we can answer this question with
existing technology we just need to
monitor the sky for more of the same
so i mean let's you know we've been
talking and been serious scientists for
a while now we can let ourselves uh
speculate a little bit more
if if it is uh artificially constructed
by an alien
civilization uh why would they do it
what is your what is your
idea about what purpose this thing could
have served to its initial
constructors yeah so again i go back to
the evidence and
we we this object was in the local
standard of rest
and sort of the galactic parking lot a
place where you can't really trace where
it came from and
why would it be in that frame you know
and one possibility
is that um there is an array of these
things
and they're used for navigation or for s
relay stations for communication uh
there could be many possibilities why
would you construct
uh like a set of systems that are at
rest in the galactic frame
um um so that's that's one possible use
that you know if
if you were to navigate through the
local volume of the galaxy you want to
have signposts or
if you wanted to communicate perhaps
relay stations if you send out
spacecrafts
um i don't know i mean it's not clear to
me and it
it could just be a some debris you know
left
over from equipment that is
dysfunctional by now
uh but the the point of the matter is
that we can tell we can tell something
artificial
can tell the difference from it from
from a piece from a rock
and clearly you know if a caveman were
to found
find the a cell phone the caveman
based on experience would say it must be
a shiny rock you know that because
that caveman saw rocks all of his life
you know that's the thing that he's
familiar with
but uh obviously with more
sophistication the caveman will conclude
oh this is an unusual
object and not something that i have
seen before and so we can do the same we
can attempt to do the same
uh by getting more data rather than
you know claiming one thing or another
based on prejudice
presumably we did uh listen to see
whether there were any
uh radio signals or other things being
given off that would be manifestly
artificial coming from
but we didn't find any yeah in fact um a
couple of weeks after it was detected i
visited the
yuri milner's home in
palo alto and discussed with him
the possible use of the telescopes
that the breakthrough listen has access
to
to monitor if there is any radio signals
coming from omumua
that was done and nothing was detected
but it doesn't tell us much because
uh perhaps we're not listening at the
right frequencies sure
you know even if it's transmitting it
could be transmitting at times
that are special not when it was passing
near us
so although interesting that you know
that possibility
uh there was no signal detected that
possibility is ruled out that
it was transmitting at the frequencies
that we were listening to
i mean it's of limited use uh for ruling
out an artificial origin
well so you mentioned um let's again be
a little bit more speculative now late
in the podcast
this is how we get so you you mentioned
the the was it the breakthrough
star shot program you're heavily
involved aside in
our attempts to contact or communicate
or visit
potential uh alien civilizations
elsewhere
yes so um i i i'm i chair the advisory
board for
uh breakthrough starshot which is a an
initiative
attempting to develop the technology
that would allow us to
uh visit other stars and
the idea there is that by physically
visiting
uh the neighborhood of a planet
we can learn much more about whether
life may exist there
and the the only problem is that the
nearest
star proxima centauri is four
and a quarter light years away uh so it
takes light four
and a quarter years to reach us from
that star
and in fact if there is in fact next to
proxima centauri there is a planet
proxima
b in the habitable zone and if there are
people out there they still do not know
the results of the election of 2016
because those signals will get there
only in february 2021 uh
and it just shows you how long it takes
for
signals to get from one star to another
but that means that
if you want to reach the nearest star
within our lifetime
uh meaning within 20 years or so which
is the goal that the yuri millionaire
posed
when he came to my office and asked
whether i would like to lead this
project
if you want to do that you need to send
a spacecraft that moves at the fifth of
the speed of light
and that is very challenging and that's
the technology that breakthrough star
shot is focusing on
and the i told him when he asked me i
told him
uh i well i have to think about it with
my students and postdocs
we thought about it for six months and
then we came up with the
suggestion that uh the only technology
that works
is pushing a light sail with a very
powerful beam
and um and having a payload that is very
lightweight
uh only a gram uh of material that
has a camera communication device
navigation
device that's possible with present day
miniaturization of electronics
and with the light cell technology uh
if you have a laser of a hundred
gigawatt shining on a
a sail that has roughly the the size of
a person
um at the outside the atmosphere um
you can launch the sail to a fifth of
the speed of light over
a few minutes uh by which time it will
be
five times farther than the moon is from
us
and then if you launch it in the right
direction it can carry the electronics
to the destination and and take a
photograph of the planet so
that would be a way of getting there uh
quickly enough and otherwise if we were
to send
for example new horizons uh
or um voyager 1 and 2
like missions it would take them 50 000
years
to reach right proxima centauri and you
know that's the time that elapsed
since the first humans left africa so if
you wanted to get
there today we would have needed to
launch the spacecraft
when the first humans left africa but
these uh breakthrough starshot one gram
little fellows would be they wouldn't be
landing anywhere they'd be
passing through these other solar
systems
and by the way yeah and by the way i
should mention that
you know if there are one gram
spacecrafts flying through the solar
system
we would never notice them well i was
going to say that the idea of this you
know you would you would push it
and it's it's you're you're pushing the
one grand by itself or is there a little
sale attached to it
there is a sale attached to it and the
sale weighs roughly a gram as well
yeah and then but but since it's so thin
it's
um less than a micron in in thickness
maybe a tenth of a micron
um and roughly the extent
the length of the height of a person you
know um
that is sufficient uh you know uh to
um bring the the payload to a fraction
of the speed of light a payload is
attached to it
there is the question of what geometry
to give to the sail you know it
um it's not clear that the flat geometry
is optimal because
it may not ride in a stable fashion on
the laser beam
uh so we considered the for example a
sphere or other geometries but
uh it's still working progress we are
currently
three challenges in this project one is
developing the
what we call the photon engine which is
the laser
that produces the very powerful beam on
earth
and the the second challenge is the
light sail
making it of a sufficiently uh strong
material
that is highly reflective and doesn't
absorb much of the laser light because
otherwise it will burn up
quickly and the third challenge is uh
communication
at those great distances that's not easy
if you want to transmit a photograph
uh from the distance of proxima centauri
b
to the earth uh it's a major
challenge actually yeah no no i i can
imagine that and
just to be super duper clear the idea
that you're sketching
kind of bears a family resemblance to
your idea for muammar with the very
large difference that a moomoo is
not moving anywhere near that fast
that's right
you know the reason i thought about the
light sail in the first place is because
i was engaged in this project now
yeah uh it's if you look at the history
of the search for
extraterrestrial signals when we
developed radio technology
for communication purposes then we
started to search for
radio signals from the sky when we
developed lasers we started to look for
that and
i mean obviously our imagination is
limited by the technologies that we have
and um we cannot imagine things that we
have not mastered ourselves so
i find it completely natural to consider
what we know
uh yeah so since we are developing light
sails and
you know breakthrough starshot is not
the first to to embark on this
challenge and the the planetary society
launched lightsail 2 and jaxa the
japanese space agency
had a demonstration of a light sail so
you know this is
maybe the the wave of the future in
terms of um space exploration and
and if we are working on that why not
imagine that another civilization
already mastered this technology
and it's very common well given that we
are just beginning
to even contemplate these technologies
and think about them
whereas other civilizations we might
bump into have been around for who knows
hundreds of millions of years
longer is there some credence to the
idea that we should be prudent and not
draw attention to ourselves should we be
worried about
uh letting people know that we're here i
think it's
it's prudent to actually look and not
make too much
noise um but unfortunately
uh you know the cat is out of the box we
already transmitted we were careless
over the past century uh the most
the the most uh loud the loudest
signals that that we produced were with
uh
uh anti-ballistic missile radars um
so they were after the second world war
there were these radars very powerful
radio transmitters that were searching
for ballistic missiles
uh from the ground and their beams were
extremely powerful they can be seen
by our radio telescopes across distances
of tens of light years
uh so we already left
some imprint and we just
we should hope that nobody uh hostile is
on the other end
receiving it because eventually we will
find out if if there is such entity
i think it's prudent not to make too
much noise uh
to just search for evidence for what is
out there
because based on human history
uh there were lots of predators uh you
know cultures that
were more advanced and were trying to um
you know conquer new lands uh to
harvest the resources there and dominate
those land and so there is no reason for
us to
be too loud i think we should be quiet
and and first listen
that certainly makes sense to me i know
some people are very eager and and
convinced themselves that if a
technology
if a civilization becomes sufficiently
technologically advanced it must also be
benevolent but
uh it's a big risk to take right when we
don't really know
for sure big risk and by the way
speaking about risk i do think
right now all of our eggs are in one
basket the earth
and it would make a lot of sense to
spread the eggs
in different baskets so that if
something catastrophic happens on earth
because we misbehave or because of some
some catastrophe
um at least
humanity will exist somewhere else and
um uh it's sort of like the gutenberg
revolution in in with the printing press
and
you know before that there were
very few copies of the bible and each of
them was handwritten and very precious
but as soon as you made the duplicates
uh with a printing press
each of each copy was not as valuable if
something bad
happened to it you could always find
other copies and
i think we as a civilization if we find
life
as we know it very precious we should
produce copies and send them
to places and so going to mars is a good
idea
uh going to beyond the solar system is a
good idea
uh we cannot rest assured that uh if we
stay here on earth
things will will go our way what is your
attitude toward the fact that other
stars are very far away
uh vis-a-vis our ability to get there do
you think that
it makes sense for human beings okay we
need to get there
you know i just wrote a scientific
american article
called noise spacecraft and the idea was
you know what is the modern version of
north's ark
sonar was worried about the flood and he
collected all the animals according to
the mythological
story of the bible he collected
representatives of
elephants and you know monkeys all all
the
animals put them on a big ark that he
constructed so that they would survive
the flood so that the precious life on
earth would
would survive the flood the the great
flood and
you can imagine doing the same thing
with a spaceship
uh but my point is that this could be a
cubesat you don't need
an noise arc which by the way the bible
mentions the dimensions of and they were
100 meters by 10 meters and so forth
very similar to the dimension
yeah but um
getting back to the point that you know
with a cubesat
you can put a very capable computer
on board in a 3d printer and
artificial intelligence equipped the
computer with the ability
to store all the information the genetic
information
let's say about the the life forms that
we find on earth
and then if it's um if we understand how
to make life artificially
then you can imagine that the 3d printer
you know once it gets to a place where
there are raw materials
uh it could make life as we know it
there so instead of transporting
like not like a noise arc transporting
people
to places you can reconstruct them there
by just carrying the information about
their dna
and using 3d printers to make life as we
know it
in distant locations so that's my
version
just a cubesat you don't need a giant
nox arc for that purpose
well i have a couple questions about
that uh
would it be the right thing to do would
it would it potentially get in the way
of
indigenous life growing up that's a good
question uh
it depends how much you value our life
relative
to uh what may
happen elsewhere uh naturally and
you know if you're a naturalist like
thoros
i live very close to walden pond where
thoreau wrote
his book and if you're a naturalist like
throw
us then you would argue we should avoid
contaminating other places
with our life and as much as possible
because
nature is precious we should let them
you know and if we perish on this planet
so be it because that's our natural way
so you can argue that you can say you
know whatever happens to humanity on
earth
you know that's our fate and uh if we
perish here nobody hears about us
in the distant future in the universe
who cares
uh the universe is large lots of things
are happening in it
and we don't amount to too much you know
we shouldn't assign significance to
to our life but on the other hand if you
think oh
actually we value life very much
and we want to maintain its long-term
future
then you want to make many copies of it
and i'm sure you know there will there
will be people on both sides
i think the naturalist approach would be
less popular based on the way we behave
with our industries and how
how much care we take of our planet if
you look at it right now
i think that most people care about
reproducing themselves rather than
maintaining the environment
so many things to talk about here yes i
think that uh there's
i i i'm intrigued by this i would want
some sort of dead man switch some sort
of dead planet switch like if we destroy
ourselves
then we you know spread ourselves
elsewhere but otherwise we can
be a little bit more that would be
interesting yeah that yeah it reminds me
of
um uh what at some point a friend of
mine said that
uh he wants to have on his website um a
button say
saying click here in
after i die and and then when you click
there you will find the full obituary
that includes all of his
scientific accomplishments it's a
similar
idea that you know when when catastrophe
hits
only then you activate your plans let me
give you a chance
to uh say one more thing about what
you've alluded to already which is sort
of the
lessons for this kind of discussion
we've been having
for how science is done both
within academia choosing topics and
valuing certain kinds of research being
done but also the fact that
whether we like it or not some of our
research is carried out in the public
eye
and you know the public on the one hand
wants to trust science on the other hand
science is sometimes not done yet and
how do we make that balance
yeah so i think the most undervalued
quality that i would like to highlight
is innovation i think it's extremely
important
for the scientific community to
encourage to cultivate innovation and
right now it doesn't look like that
a lot of the funding for grants uh is
given to mainstream uh ideas that
you know you just add a nuance on an
existing theme and
and the reason is simple because the
people on the committees the selection
committees are
mainstream people that want to create
echo chambers where they
advocate how significant their
contribution to the field was
and the way to achieve that is by
educating students
to reproduce what you've done and so
that you get this echo chamber
of people saying the same things uh with
more details
um it's just a mechanism for boosting
uh their ego in some sense and and if
you have people like that on selection
committed
committees they would try to uh fund the
projects that support um uh their
activity throughout their career and
and continues to do along the same line
rather than
innovate and criticize and be um
and be open-minded about alternatives
and i think that's bad for science
and in fact if you look at the the
public sector the commercial sector you
find
that companies like google
do have within them
blue sky research and that was true of
bell labs
in the old days and a lot of innovation
came from that a lot of nobel prizes
and so if the commercial sector
recognizes the value
of innovation uh more than the academic
community that's
an unfortunate situation that we are at
and i think it should change i think
there should be a fixed fraction of the
funds
allocated to innovative thinking it will
also change the atmosphere that
there would be less bullying of anything
that looks different you know if you go
to kindergartens you see
kids always bullying those that look
different
and the scientific community does the
same thing you know when whenever a
proposal for an idea that is different
than the one that is commonly adopted is
is is made then people bully that
proposal
and that's i think that's bad for the
health of the field it's bad for science
we should be open-minded we should
criticize based on
uh evidence and and and rational
arguments so
that's point number one the second is
you know
um kids uh often are innocent when they
explore the world they don't do it for
their own
uh for boosting their ego and so forth i
would very much like my colleagues to
behave more like kids you know like
being open-minded and discussing
possibilities uh without dismissing them
ahead of time
and i wrote an article about this to the
harvard gazette in which i encouraged my
colleagues to be more
uh behave more like kids that that would
be my
my wish uh so both in terms of funding
and in terms of
interactions with each other i i see uh
that a lot of work needs to be done to
make the scientific inquiry
more honest and straightforward now i'm
100
in agreement with you there and i've
come across the you know the bullying if
you know
there's a thing that grows up as a
scientist matures where they try to
discriminate between
good work and bad work and it's not
always completely objective and they
have their
biases and it's just remarkably fast how
quick
scientists can knock down work that
they're not familiar with but on the
other hand i recognize
there's a lot of crack pottery out there
also and it's not worth supporting so
it's just so hard to get that balance
exactly right
yeah this is called natural selection
that
you know i think the evidence evidence
and data should be
the rulers rather than people's opinions
so
you know what you find are fields that
are saturated with
subjective judgments as to what is
appropriate to look
at without any evidence
you have string theory for five decades
being very popular no evidence and it's
now not even
predictive as to what we might look for
in order to falsify it and then
you know just have these cultures that
are self-perpetuating
without a need for evidence anymore
evidence is not the oxygen that drives
them
it's more intellectual gymnastics and
i find that dangerous because um that's
the way aristotle
operated you know the ancient greeks and
we've learned a lot since then that
evidence is extremely important for the
progress that we have and
we've made progress but but there is
some retreat
and there are even people advocating
that we live in a simulation which i
find
uh you know just like being on drugs in
a way
[Laughter]
well this is exactly the problem one
person's scientific investigation is
another person's uh
you know waste of time and so i'm
agreeing with you in principle
i don't have any concrete suggestions
for
making it better but it's something that
we should try to think about but but
let's close up by uh asking a very
different question you
you're very well known for working on
many different kinds of things
we've been talking about uh search for
extraterrestrial life and muammar and
stuff like that but you're also the
founder of the black hole initiative and
so forth
let me give you this opportunity to say
what is the most interesting thing
you're working on right now that has
nothing to do
with extraterrestrial life
um well we think that we discovered the
nearest black hole
and it's um about a thousand times the
mass of the sun
and it's at a distance of a few hundred
light years from us
uh completely unexpected we found some
evidence for it
the paper is being refereed right now uh
to me that's very exciting uh because
you know a black hole is a place if if
i'm asked
what would i like to visit i would like
to visit the vicinity of a black hole
not get
into it because then you have a limited
life
inside before you get your body gets
torn apart but
looking at it from a close distance
would be quite amazing and um
so actually at a conference at the
annual conference of the black hole
uh in initiative that we have at harvard
that i'm the founding director of
uh i once uh suggested in my closing
remarks i said
you know a black hole represents uh one
place where you can actually test
string theory and the string theories
should
uh plan on you know on a field trip you
know if we have a nearby black hole we
should go there
in the next conference so that they can
test they will test their theory by
entering the black hole and getting
close to the singularity
and when i suggested that um
nimar khani hamad shouted from the
audience
you you must have an ulterior motive for
sending
string theories into a black hole to
which i didn't respond
you did not respond and i will not make
you respond right now we'll let the
audience think about that so
avi lope thanks so much for incredibly
provocative and fascinating conversation
my pleasure thank you
[Music]
you